>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Coming up next to the
stage we have a dynamic duo.
They're already here joining
me on my left and my right.
Travis Foster; give him
a round of applause.
[applause] He has been working as an
illustrator for more than 25 years
and he runs an illustration agency
that helps out other artists.
Ethan Long, [applause]
he's an author
and an illustrator who's
worked on more than 85 books
and he's created the Disney Channel
series, "Tasty Time with ZeFronk."
Together they have teamed
up to create a picture book
with the title, "Give
Me Back My Book!"
Now, who here in this
room loves reading?
[cheering] All right, well then you
have a lot in common with the fun
and funny characters that are in
this book that they've created.
After their talk you can
get books signed from 11
to 12 p.m. over in that direction.
Please give a warm round of applause
for Travis Foster and Ethan Long.
[applause]
>> Ethan Long: Thank you!
Can you hear me?
>> Travis Foster: Can you hear me?
>> Yes!
>> I can hear you.
>> Barely.
>> Yeah. [laughs]
>> So we're going to -- we
want to start out first by --
we're going on a bear hunt!
We're going --
>> On a bear hunt!
>> Oh, that was the
last presentation.
>> Last presentation Ethan.
>> Thanks for having
Travis and I today.
My name is Ethan Long.
I'm a children's book
author and illustrator.
This is my friend.
>> Travis Foster and
I'm Robin, he is Batman.
[laughter]
>> I'm the quarterback.
He's the writer's hubris.
>> Wide receiver.
>> What we came here to talk
about today is our funny
book, "Give Me Back My Book!"
How many of you guys like to read?
[cheering] How many of you
have read this book already?
>> Me!
>> [laughing] Chirp, chirp, chirp.
>> Who said, "me"?
>> I know we're not Kate DiCamillo
but at least you can
know what our books are.
[laughter]
>> I didn't know it
came out already though.
>> It comes out next week but maybe
they were, you know walking around.
>> September seventh.
>> I called Travis -- I was --
>> He called me a knucklehead.
>> I called you a knucklehead?
>> Knucklehead.
But I was okay with that.
>> [laughing] I called
Travis one day
because I was having trouble
coming up with some book concepts
and I thought I wanted to team
up with somebody to do a fun book
where one illustrator
would draw one character
and one illustrator would
draw the other character
and they would interact.
So I thought that was a good idea.
So I called Travis up and he said --
>> I said, "Ethan is this a joke?
Because you're so great at drawing.
Why are you calling me for?"
>> Shucks.
[laughter] Well, this
guy is so talented.
We've known each other
for a long time.
We met in college back
in 19 -- in the 1980s.
>> About the 1800s, yeah.
>> Back in the 1880s.
>> Yeah, 1880.
>> And he got to be -- we've
gotten to be pretty good friends
over the years, good colleagues.
So I thought he'd be a perfect fit.
He's professional.
He's fast.
He's funny.
>> And I'm good looking.
[laughter]
>> I was going to say,
"He's funny -- looking."
>> Funny looking.
Exactly.
>> But how we wanted
to start today is sort
of starting a little different
than how it's actually playing out,
but what we want to do is we would
like to draw the characters for you.
Travis is going to start
first and tell us a little bit
about his character, Redd.
And then I'm going to
draw a little bit about --
and talk a little bit
about my character, Bloo.
And then we are going
to read the book.
And then we have a special
surprise at the end,
if you're ready for that.
Everybody ready for this?
[cheering] Take it away Travis!
>> Okay, so man I've been
drawing ever since I was like this
and I would get in trouble
in class when I was supposed
to be doing my math or
history or geography.
I was drawing in the book.
So getting to make a living drawing
pictures is absolutely my dream job.
So they asked you before,
"Who likes to read?"
Is there anybody out
here that likes to draw?
I like to see those hands because --
anyway, we'll talk
about that in a minute.
So my character is Redd and I'm
going to start with his blue nose.
So I'm going to start
with the blue nose.
>> It's too big.
>> It is too big.
All right, then we're
going to just do the eyes.
>> Those are cute.
>> Yeah, five teeth
on this character
and he can chew his food pretty
good with those five teeth.
>> Wow!
>> Smile, tongue, and
my character happens
to have a little bit of hair.
So I start --
>> Hey!
>> Hey! All right, and he's
fuzzy kind of all over.
So I just put fuzzy all over.
Now, it's interesting because
my character has big arms
like a gorilla and tiny
legs like a chicken.
So let's start with the arms.
And even on the arms we
have a little bit of hair.
What kind of stuff could
he possibly be holding?
I don't have any idea what he likes.
And so --
>> That looks a little
like a hedgehog.
>> Well, it -- we know it's
going to be Redd when we're done.
>> Okay.
>> Hedgehog -- Redd.
All right, so then let's go ahead
and add his legs, some socks.
He's got white socks on and a shoe.
We'll do the other leg, sock, shoe.
Let's go ahead and have him holding
-- you know, I tell you what,
I'm feeling like an ice cream cone.
>> Wow!
>> All right, and then let's
go ahead and do his big glasses
because my character has glasses.
Ethan, you have glasses, but --
>> Yeah, your glasses are
better than my glasses.
>> Big glasses make it
easier to read with.
And then we'll connect the
character and there is Redd.
>> What do you think kids?
>> That's done.
[ Cheering ]
Not too bad.
Not too shabby.
>> That is excellent.
That's amazing.
What I forgot to show
you is -- we wanted to --
when I said we kind of -- you
know you plan these things
and then you actually get up here
and you start talking
and you forget stuff.
So what we planned to talk
about was when we were kids,
how we drew all the time and
how, you know we loved --
he had friends, I had
bowties, and we just decided,
you know turn it into a business.
>> And he still has
the nice red bowtie.
>> It's not the same
one, but I started young.
This is the original drawing
that Travis sent me originally
when we first started
about talking --
when we first started about talking
about this project he sent me this.
And I was like, "Wow!
That's cool!"
And then I sent him that
and he said, "Oh, wow!
That's cool!"
And then I sent him that.
He said -- well, he said, "What
are we going to have them do?"
And I said, "Why don't we just
have them, you know arguing
over a book or something?"
So I sent him that.
Well, as the process goes you
start working with your editors.
You start working with
your art directors.
your publishers.
Things change.
You start streamlining the idea.
It turns into this.
This is what it's turned into.
And when you buy the book
today -- for how much Travis?
17.99?
>> 16.99.
>> 16.99? You'll see that the
characters have changed a lot.
Now, as Travis colors his
-- are you about done sir?
>> I am done.
>> Okay. I'm going to go ahead
and draw my character, Bloo.
>> Now, one of the things you've
got to understand about me
and Ethan is opposites attract.
And Ethan and I --
he's fast, I'm slow.
So it might have taken me three
or four minutes -- Ethan's quick.
So --
>> I went to visit
Travis in Nashville
and he took me out in the car.
We went for lunch.
Oh, my gosh.
I was sitting in the passenger
seat going, "Oh, my God!
Speed up brother!"
>> I'm too slow.
Driving too slow.
>> Speed up!
So, my character, Bloo --
I draw lots of different
characters over the years.
This one I wanted to stay as simple
as possible and I wanted it to stay
as -- I wanted it to
be opposite of his.
His was fuzzy with glasses.
He didn't have any ears.
His nose was vertical.
He had this furry body
with footwear and socks.
He had this fancy character and I
said, "I just want something simple.
I just want the simplest
possible shape that I can draw."
And I figured the best
possible shape
that I could draw was just
like a jellybean shape.
>> Very nice.
>> So, yeah.
It was very clean.
Kind of an egg, kind
of a birth of the --
this is kind of the
birth of the character.
I then decided that --
I said, "Well, what kind of
a character could this be?"
And I said, "Well, I have this -- ."
I said, "I'll just draw some ears."
And I just went -- [swooping nose]
[drooping noise] From there I decide
to put a nose on him because
the noses are important.
They're important for smelling.
[sniffing noise] They're important
for putting it into
someone's business.
[laughter] They're
important for a lot of things.
So I wanted to make
sure that he had a nose.
The correct nose.
What I also did was
I flipped the colors.
I took Travis's red
color, flipped it.
I made the nose red
and the body blue,
rather than the body
red and the nose blue.
I got a little -- I put a
little highlight on the nose
to make it look shiny and dewy.
>> Nice.
>> It's all dewy.
Then I decided to -- well,
every jellybean needs arms.
So --
So how fast I did that?
He could never do that.
>> Slow.
>> He could never do that.
Then, for me it's all about
the emotion of the character.
It's all about the
action, the body language.
Travis does ice cream
cones and stuff.
I'm thinking about deeper things.
>> Deeper life.
>> Deeper, Travis.
>> Yeah, deeper.
So where are the eyes?
>> So I'll get there.
I'll get there.
[laughter] So --
>> Nice.
>> Oh! He has a tongue.
>> Looking good.
>> Thanks Trav.
And then the eyes.
So the eyes are very
important to me.
Most of the characters that I draw
have a little twinkle in them.
You can see in Bloo on the screen,
he's got a little twinkle
in his eye.
So I try to leave that
same twinkle in their eye.
>> Very nice.
Looking good.
>> How much time Trav?
How much time?
>> Looking good.
>> How much time?
Ten minutes!
Good.
>> We're 10 minutes in and
we have 10 minutes left.
>> We have plenty of time.
>> Ten minutes in.
>> So that was essentially Bloo.
Oh, and then every rabbit --
jellybean rabbit --
has to have a tail.
And that was essentially
the beginning
of this beautiful friendship that we
have, this beautiful collaboration.
What we did from there is we turned
these characters into a story.
So my job with our team
is to come up with a story
and write the storyline,
write the plot.
I did that.
I typed it out, sent it to Travis.
We didn't think too much
in this process did we?
>> No.
>> No. We didn't sit
and think about stuff.
We just did it and sent it.
When I sent it to Travis what he
did is he laid out the whole book.
And as we read it you'll see
what Travis did with the layouts.
>> We're going to read
the book for [inaudible]?
>> The action.
Yeah, the action, the pacing.
I tweaked it here and there,
but Travis did the layouts.
So maybe we should read now
and show you the layouts.
That would be great.
>> We're actually going to -- ?
>> We're going to read.
Yeah.
>> Let's do it.
>> Okay. Just for the record,
I always take off the cover
because it gets in the way.
>> This one's [inaudible].
>> Because I'm OCD.
>> Whoa! This one's glued in man.
>> Yeah.
>> We got another one?
Look, I can keep my cover on.
>> You can do that?
>> Yeah, I can do that.
>> How do you do that?
>> I don't know.
[inaudible] Never mind.
I got it.
>> [sighs] Okay.
>> Got it.
>> Are you ready?
>> I'm ready.
>> You got it?
>> I got it.
>> I'm going to try to
read and click the thing.
I know, it's tough.
I live a tough life man.
Okay?
>> Pat stomach, rub head?
>> I rub my head too much.
[laughter] Okay.
You start.
>> All right.
>> No, start with the cover.
Dude!
>> Oh!
>> Dude!
>> "Give Me Back My Book!"
>> By?
>> Travis Foster.
>> And Ethan Long.
>> There you go.
All right.
>> Hey, wait a second Redd.
That's my book!
>> I beg your pardon Bloo,
but this book is mine.
>> No! My book is green
and has lots of pages.
I'm 100 percent sure
that is my book!
>> Well, as you can see,
I have a green book too.
It has many pages, about
as many as yours I suppose.
>> I want my book!
>> Then go find it.
>> Oh, I found it right there!
>> I cannot part with my green book.
It has a hard cover, a nice spine,
the pages turn from right to left,
and if you are adventurous,
from left to right.
There are letters on each page
and they are gathered together
to form words that have
meaning when you read them.
>> All books do that!
>> Oh, yes.
But my book has a table of contents,
funny little things called chapters,
and every now and again there's
something called an illustration.
>> Mine has all of those things.
>> Wait, does yours
have a bent page?
>> Yes, I bent that page!
>> Well, you shouldn't have.
>> Aha! It is my book!
>> It is mine now.
>> No, it's mine!
>> Give it to me!
>> Let it go!
>> I mean it.
Let go!
>> Get your hands off it!
>> It is my book!
>> Give me back my book!
We probably missed a couple there.
>> That's okay.
Much grace.
>> Ha!
>> Good voice.
>> You like that one?
>> I like that.
>> Ha!
>> That's good.
Get back here bookworm!
>> Bring back that book!
>> She's fast.
>> Hold on.
Hold on. I might have skipped.
>> No.
>> They need to soak that in.
>> What did we miss?
>> I missed it.
>> Oh.
>> Okay.
>> Where are we?
>> We're right there.
>> Oh, look at that picture.
That's nice.
Look at that screen.
>> [laughing] This is my book.
You like that one?
Want me to do it again?
This is my book.
>> [whispering noises] Uh oh.
Here, let me see.
I'll connect it.
[laughter] Are you on?
>> Yes. Am I?
>> You're on.
>> Okay. Let's do it!
>> Let's do it.
You got to watch these cords man.
>> I know, I'm going
to put mine up here.
>> Go ahead.
>> This will make the perfect bait.
>> Wait, you got to move forward.
>> I know.
I'm doing too many
things at once Trav.
>> Come on man.
[inaudible]
>> I'm good.
>> All right.
Yes -- why don't you
start over on that one.
>> [disappointed noise] Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> This will make the perfect bait!
>> Yes. The cover, the spine and
pages will be hard to resist.
The letters will be too
beautiful to look away from.
>> The words will blow her mind.
>> She'll adore the
table of contents.
She'll drool over the chapters.
>> The illustrations will
make her eyes explode!
>> [uncertain noise]
Is that a bit page.
Oh my. [laughter] Thank you.
>> Thanks mom.
>> Wow! This is such a great book!
>> Oh, such suspense.
It may be the best book ever.
That sounds like an amazing book.
I'll trade you this
book for that book.
>> Well, I don't know.
This is a pretty great book.
>> Just a little disclaimer;
this shift of voices
might blow my larynx out.
So just be prepared for
meds to come -- medical.
>> Medics.
>> Please!
Okay. Bring it over here
and we'll trade you.
Ha!
>> We got our book back Bloo.
>> [cheering] I can't
wait to read our book!
>> Did we say, "Our book?"
>> Yes, I think we did.
>> Our green book with the
cover in letters and words?
>> And that silly bent page.
>> [laughing] I can't
pick you up Ethan.
I -- [laughing] I can't
-- I don't know.
I can't pick you up man.
I love our book.
>> Me too.
[ Cheering ]
Hey! Those are my glasses.
>> You don't wear glasses.
>> Oh, yeah.
The end.
>> One more thing.
[ Applause ]
>> This is the best book ever.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
[cheering] Okay.
[applause] I was just told
that we have five minutes left.
>> Five minutes left?
>> Five minutes left.
Tell them what we're
going to do Trav.
>> What are we going to do?
>> Tell them what we're going to do.
>> We have a special
presentation from our audience.
And if you love to
draw raise one hand.
And if you love to read
raise the other hand.
And if you think you might
want to come up on the stage
and draw your favorite character
in two minutes then stand
up and raise both hands.
Stand up.
>> Oh, here we go!
>> Who's the competitors?
If you want to come up on the stage
and draw your favorite character
in two minutes -- okay, we're going
to pick two from the audience today.
>> She's going to pick two.
>> That's right.
>> We don't want that pressure.
>> You might want to take your --
>> Oh, sign it Trav.
>> I did.
>> I'll sign mine.
>> We'll set this down.
I just -- I'll sign.
Hi. My name is Travis.
>> All right.
>> Name?
>> Lauren.
[assumed spelling]
Hi. Lauren.
Do you want more than one
color or would you just
like black and blue maybe or -- ?
>> I'm going to make
the [inaudible].
>> Do you have a red over there?
>> I don't have a red.
I just -- I need a blue.
>> Okay. Do you have the red
marker over there somewhere?
>> I have the red marker
in my pocket Travis.
>> Thank you.
[inaudible]
>> How are you?
>> Now, any character
you want in two minutes.
All right, so when
are we going to start?
[yelling] Go ahead and take your
-- you can put your markers up here
with the tops off if you want.
So you can have them.
All right, Ethan.
>> Hold on Travis.
>> All right man.
>> Okay. So what's your name?
Isabella. [assumed
spelling] Nice to meet you.
I'm Ethan.
>> And tell me your name again.
>> Lauren.
This is Lauren.
Everybody give a round of
applause for our brave artists.
[applause]
>> Did you say brave artists?
>> Brave.
>> Brave. Very courageous.
>> To come up here and
draw -- this is fantastic.
>> What we'd like you to do --
>> We've got two minutes for
them to draw their favorite --
>> Yes. Does anyone
have a stopwatch?
Do you have a stopwatch?
Everybody's got a phone.
Two minutes.
>> Two minutes.
>> Okay, what we'd like
you to do is you don't have
to draw our characters, although
it's legally required of you.
No, you can draw whatever
you'd like.
>> Any character you want.
>> You can draw whatever
character's your favorite character,
but you have two minutes.
This is how we work.
We work on a time clock.
So we would like you to draw your
favorite character in two minutes.
You think you can do it?
>> All right.
>> You think you can do it?
>> Is the timer ready?
>> Do it. Timer ready.
>> Go.
>> Go!
>> All right, they've
got two minutes.
Now --
>> My girl's winning.
[laughter]
>> My girl is doing fantastic.
If you like to read and you like
to draw and you like people to read
to you then it might be someday at
some point, and it doesn't even have
to be that long, you can
start writing your own books
and illustrating your own books.
And with today's technology, with
-- you can print one book at a time
for like 20 bucks and I encourage
anybody that has that desire
to go ahead and start
and practice and do it.
It's like anything else.
Like if you're good at the
violin you have to practice.
Or piano. Just make books and
share those books with your friends
and family because you never know.
I mean the next thing you
know Ethan might call you
and ask you to do a book with him.
>> I might.
>> He might.
It might happen.
I was super surprised
when he called me.
>> I was super excited
that you said yes.
Okay, let's check back with our --
>> How much time -- ?
>> Let's check back.
>> Halfway.
A minute in.
We've got one more minute left.
>> Okay.
>> Our brave artists, courageous.
>> She's got some blue hair.
>>She's finished!
Less than two minutes.
Give me a high five!
[cheering]
>> Do it. Wow!
Look at that.
>> You've got more time.
Keep going.
>> Tell them -- tell
us what we drawing?
[inaudible response]
It's Harry Potter?
Will you please sign it and
put your date on it for me?
All right, hand me my
drawing and Ethan's.
>> Thirty seconds.
>> Don't feel the pressure.
>> Thank you.
Yeah. All right.
Here E.
>> Great.
>> Here's yours.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, thank you Lauren.
That looks fantastic.
>> Can you wait.
Yeah, wait.
>> Yeah, I'm going
to wait for you man.
I'm going to wait too.
>> Not for me.
For her.
>> If you put 2017.
Two zero one seven.
>> You done?
Nice. Okay everyone give
a big round of applause!
[applause] Okay, you sign your
name here and put the date.
That would be great.
>> Okay, we're going to
carefully take this down.
>> Isabella and you can just
put today's year like 17.
>> You did an excellent job.
>> Yeah like a little
[dot noise] and 17.
>> Be very careful.
>> There you go, that's good.
Awesome. [applause] Okay,
now Travis and I spoke of --
>> Will you hold this one for me?
>> Yeah. You can hold
this one for me.
We would like to keep these
drawings and in return.
>> We'd like you to
have that drawing.
Is that okay?
>> We'd like you to
have those drawings.
>> Thank you.
And we have a few --
>> What we're going to do is
we're going to put it in the tube.
We're going to put it in a tube
so they can carry them around
and not get them destroyed.
And we're going to do the same.
>> I think we're out of
time you want to thank -- ?
>> And we're out of time.
>> Thank them?
>> Thank you very much!
>> Enjoy yourself in Washington DC!
Hope to see you around.
>> Thank you so much
for coming out today.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.